[Musique]
ah non c'est pas
non non
non il faisait partie du paysage
cinématographique et musical français
depuis si longemps c'est aujourd'hui
qu'ont lieu les obsèques de Jane Birkin
des obsèques qui ont lieu à Paris vous
allez voir beaucoup de monde présent et
pour parler de ces obstèes je suis avec
Pascaline Podevin chef de service pour
Le Figaro Madame bonjour bonour
Pascaline bonjour merci d'être avec nous
avec vous on va retracer la carrière de
Jan Birkin vous n'hésitez pas les
internautes du Figaro à poser vos
question à rendre hommage à Jan Birkin
on a histoire de légende qui nous
demande à quelle heure commenceront les
obsèques de sa définte idole les
obsèques commenceront à 10h et seront
transmis sur un grand écran qu'on pourra
vous vous montrer on vous montrera la
scène dans quelques instants Pascaline
c'est un finalement un monument français
qu'on enterre aujourd'hui ouais c'est un
monument français on disait que c'était
la la plus anglaise des françaises mais
c'est vrai qu'elle appartenait tellement
elle a tellement contribué à contribué
pardon à façonner la culture française
il y a les films il y a la musique
l'histoire avec ginsbourg mais on peut
pas la réduire juste justement juste à
ce couple ce qu' a beaucoup été été fait
depuis son essès il y a une semaine
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a incarné une
certaine idée de la femme de la femme
française une certaine idée de la
liberté de l'imenspation féminine aussi
une femme très engagée aussi une femme
militante donc je pense que toutes cette
facette là font qu'elle a vraiment été
une personnalité importante de la
culture française oui importante et
marquante et d'ailleurs on va le voir
dans quelques instants sur ces sur des
images vous allez voir le monde qui se
qui s'est rassemblé à Paris énormément
de gens qui sont présents pour l'instant
devant cette église saint-roc à Paris
vous allez le voir Jane Birkin on le
disait c'est c'est une Anglaise qui
arrive qui est arrivit à Paris et qui et
qui et qui explose finalement aux yeux
du grand public à Paris oui elle elle
elle explose je pense que quand elle
arrive on est dans les swinging sixties
l'Angleterre est emblématique de ce
courant-là les miniupes cette espèce de
frénésie la danse la la liberté la fête
elle arrive elle incarne un peu tout ça
euh et ensuite elle elle va elle va
voilà vraiment accompagner euh les les
les évolutions culturelles les
évolutions de la société également mais
il y a une chose importante donc c'est
une anglaise comme vous le dites elle ne
perdra jamais cet accent qui la
caractérisé si bien qui a été parfois
même imité on entend endait sa voix même
au-delà du timbre de voix c'était
l'accent qui comptait qu'elle n'a jamais
perdu elle avait une façon unique de
parler
français quelque part de s'approprier la
langue française et ce mélange des gen
on a fait une personnalité unique et un
petit bout d'Angleterre qui dépassait
même je pense justement les frontières
elle était c'était plus l'Angleterre
c'était la France c'était le territoire
janberkin alors vous voyez là ce sont
des images en direct depuis Paris une
full compact qui est devant devant cette
église saint-roc où les obsèques sont
retransmises on le disait aussi c'est
quelqu'un qui était très apprécié et
très très suivi finalement très très
apprécié très aimé je pense qu'elle
dégageait
même quand on quand on revoit son
parcours quand on lit ses ses interviews
c'était quelqu'un d'une grande liberté
d'une grande bienveillance le mot peut
paraître galvodé aujourd'hui mais je
pense qu'elle l'a porté et ce dès les
débuts à l'époque où justement ce mot
n'était peut-être pas à la mode c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais été dans le
jugement quelqu'un qui a vécu sa vie de
manière très libre sans se soucier du
regard des autres et je pense
qu'elle-même justement ne faisait pas
l'insulte aux autres de porter de porter
un regard surplombant pourtant c'était
une star quelqu'un qui était quand même
à une position culturelle de pouvoir
quelqu'un qui était voilà qui avait une
stature imposante mais qui restait
désarmante parce qu'on la sentait proche
de chacun alors on va on va retracer sa
vie depuis le début elle grandit à
Londres d'un père qui est commandant
pour la Royal nvy et d'une mère qui est
actrice oui donc très jeune elle a vécu
comme ça dans un dans un milieu sa mère
lui a inculqué ça un milieu un milieu
artistique euh son frère aussi et non
son son frère est réalisateur et elle
s'est marié très jeune à 19 ans à John
Barry compositeur de musique de film
musique de James Bond notamment donc
voilà sa vie a toujours été marquée par
par l'art la musique le le le le jeu la
culture John Barry avec qui elle se
marie très vite vous disez compositeur
compositeur compositeur très célèbre
pour James Bond mais ça se passe pas
très bien non leur mariage a duré je
crois 2 ans ils ont une fille à Kate
Barry qui a été safé qui est
malheureusement décédé il y a quelques
années dans des circonstances tragiqu
c'est une mort qui l'a qui l'a marqué
qui l'a brisé euh mais oui voilà très
jeune un enfant ça se passe mal euh elle
débarque en France alors
euh je vais prendre vos commentaires
Nini Ratsimba sincère condolance à la
famille benkari condoléance Anouchka que
Jane repose en paix voilà beaucoup
beaucoup de messages une fois de plus de
de d'internautes qui qui viennent
exprimer leur peine vous êtes très
nombreux à nous suivre il y a on vous
disait beaucoup de gens qui vont suivre
ces obsèques en direct euh elle arrive
elle arrive en France alors un peu enfin
elle elle arrive en France et un peu
avant ça on va la voir au cinéma pour la
première fois alors elle avait des
petits rôes un peu avant et elle va
tourner dans un film qui est un peu un
ovni on va dire et qui s'appelle blow
voilà blow up alors vous m'excusez j'ai
pas l'année en tête mais c'est un film
qui marque vraiment 1966 c'est un film
qui marque vraiment son
époque c'est un film qui fait scandale
elle joue le rôle d'un mannequin topless
je crois avec avec donc cette histoire
une enquête sur un photographe qui est
témoin d'un crime via son téléobjectif
il la prend photo elle est topl ce sont
des images où on voit le corps de la
femme comme ça dénudé très sexualisé
mais de manière très arti filmé de
manière très artistique aussi dans les
swinging six pardon et se vend de
libération le public est quand même un
peu surpris choqué de voir cela mais
donc dès ses débuts c'est un petit rôle
je crois vraiment on la voit pas
beaucoup on la voit très peu mais dès
ses débuts euh
elle incarne comme ça ça se vend de de
de liberté de de de liberté dans dans le
corps féminin elle apparaît elle n'est
jamais vulgaire
elle est elle est libre tout simplement
et aussi déjà elle impose sa silhouette
cette frange cette silhouette longéine
qui va être quand même qui va inspirer
des des des générations et des
générations ensuite oui elle disait que
quand elle était jeune elle était
beaucoup moquée parce qu'elle avait un
physique androgide en fait elle
ressemblit plus à un garçon qu'à une
fille du coup elle était très moqué
quand elle était jeune ouais ouais ouais
et et pourtant ce ce physique enfin on
sait à quel point il va devenir je à son
corps c'est le cas de le dire défondant
parce qu'elle n'a pas non plus inspiré
ça mais bon dans les années 90 Kate Moss
le côté brindiy et tout vient de là
parfois justement donc avec ces ces
limites où on a pu ça a pu devenir une
injonction à trop de de mur trop de
maigreur elle n'était pas comme ça du
tout et je pense qu'elle elle n'était
pas du tout dans dans ce trucl mais oui
cette silhouette
androginene disruptive à l'époque va
devenir un canon de beauté euh ensuite
on disait elle arrive en France alors
déjà pour pour une petite anecdote que
j'ai entendu c'est que en fait elle a
fait ce film parce que John Barry lui a
dit tu nen seras jamais capable et du
coup elle lui dit bah non bah du coup je
vais le faire elle aime bien ça au
moment de son de sa rupture avec John
Barry elle part en France et là elle
rencontre Serge ginbourg qui est le
personnage de sa vie oui le percentage
de sa vie de sa vie il se rendcre sur un
film là aussi slogan euh au début c'est
pas du tout le coup de fout de remédiia
elle ça se passe même très mal il voilà
ça ça se passe mal euh il se trouve
moche tous les deux mutuellement euh
lui la charie beaucoup la charie sur son
accent elleelle se demande ce que c'est
que ce Français arrogant cet homme à la
tête de chou qui n'a pas encore ce noml
mais bon qui qui sait et puis peu à peu
l'alchimie va enfin c'est irrésistible
l'alchimie va grandir entre eux et voilà
slogan avec slogan on assiste à la
naissance de l'un des couples mythiques
de la culture française et qui va durer
et qui va sergansbourg va lui écrire de
nombreuses chansons pour elle voà ouais
de nombreuses chansons alors évidemment
la plus emblématique c'est je t'aim moi
non plus euh sorti en 69 si je me trompe
pas il a pas écrite pour elle il a
écrite pour
bardau il a une liaison 2 ans avant
Bardo était marié le mari de Bardo a
fait interdire la chanson de toute façon
qu'elle était c'était un scandale euh et
donc il réenregistre la chanson avec Jan
Birkin lui dira toujours que ce qui a
fait le succès et le le scandale
également de la chanson c'est le fait
qu'elle chante un octave plus haut que
Brigitte bardau doncelle a cette voix
très flutée très aigu il dit que ça crée
un trouble comme ça cette fragilité dans
une chanson aussi explicite c'est ce
trouble là qui va rendre la chanson
aussi magnétique aussi fascinante je
pense aussi que c'est le fait d'entendre
une femme qui assume son désir qui en a
fait encore une fois sans jamais de
vulgarité qui a fait de cette chanson le
classique qu'il est aujourd'hui oui et
il il y avait ces motsl qui disent que
elle a toujours réussi à être très sexy
sans être vulgaire et et elle a réussi à
rester sur cette ligne de crête quelque
part et ça a été un peu l'exploit
qu'elle a réussi toute sa vie finalement
ouais je crois c'est c'est c'est un
mystère quand quand on est quand on est
une femme ou même un homme quand on voit
ce genre de parcours on peut être que
fasciné par cette espèce de magnétisme
et je pense que c'est un mélange de de
de liberté de respect de soi de respect
de l'autre aussi et
elle assumait en fait tout ce qu'elle
faisait et puis la grâce quoi la grâce
la grâce inée qu'elle avait l'élégance
iné euh faisait que voilà tout était
tout était charmant jamais gratuit très
beau oui y son son timbre de voix vous
disz que c'était très particulier son
accent et aussi son de voix
effectivement qui sont très spéciaux
finalement qu'elle
avait au niveau de sa filmographie en 69
elle tourne la piscine un film aussi
assez mythique avec d'énormes stars elle
se retrouve un peu au milieu de tout ça
elle aussi parce qu'elle connaît Serge
gbourg finalement ouais oui oui elle
connait ça mais elle elle arrive à jouer
un rôle d'ingénu elle joue de la fille
d'un ami du personnage joué par alin
Delon qui arrive donc dans cette maison
paradisiaque dans le sud de le sud de la
France je crois avec cette piscine
emblématique Romy schneeder qui est
sublime tout le monde est sublime dans
ce film de toute façon c'est pour ça
qu'on continue à le regarder aujourd'hui
et elle est l'élément qui va faire
advevenir le drame en fait c'est
l'élément disruptif encore une fois sa
beauté son ingéniosité remettre tout en
cause le couple le couple de le couple
que joue que joue pardon Alain Delon Ry
Schneider les deux personnages tout va
voler en éclat et elle le fait d'une
manière elle a une candur et en même
temps un côté très très vénéneux il y a
ça n'appartenait qu'à elle cette manière
d'incarner une femme fatale euh avec
beaucoup de naïveté de candur sans pour
autant jouer totalement les saintes n
touch enfin c'était un équilibre encore
une fois très précaire mais qu'elle
maîtrisait à merveille voilà h
euh du coup ça c'est ça ça partie
cinématographique dans le même temps P
ce temp-l elle elle est elle continue de
de de de de de chanter de nombreuses
chansons on disait donc ce fameux je
t'aime moi non plus beaucoup faire elle
va sortir beaucoup d'albums qui jusqu'en
87 vont être écrits finalement par Serge
g ouais ouais même après leur rupture il
y a un ce très bel album Babylon in
Babylon euh 83 19 83 voilà qui est là
encore une fois troublant il savait la
là aussi c'était un jeu drôle parfois
elle était presque une actrice en fait
il lui écrivait des chansons comme un
réalisateur ou un scénariste peut écrire
des rôles pour une actrice Babylon une
Babylon qui est un de ses plus beaux
albums euh on la voit apparaître sur la
pochette très maquillée pas du tout à
l'inverse de la birkine qui a imposé ce
style très décontracté Jean t-shirt
panier en osier frange là elle a un
chignon elle est très maquillée elle a
un rouge à lèv rouge c'est parce que ce
disque est inspiré d'Hollywood des stars
hollywoodiennes comme ça de marilyine
monondro de tout ce meet hollywoodien
elle arrive à l'incarner tout en restant
euh incroyablement elle-même parce qu'il
y a ce grain de voix parce qu' a les
mélodies de ginbourg et ça donne lieu à
des chansons voà les deux Soushi Babylon
Babylon c'est des classiques
effectivement alors je continue de lire
vos messages Sophie Eden
versau ou qui qui nous disent voilà qui
aussi rendent hommage à Jan beking
grande actrice vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à nous suivre les obsèques ont
lieu dans un quart d'heure qu'on pourra
suivre sur le grand écran qui est posé
devant cette église saint-roc à à Paris
pour revenir un peu avec Serge ginbourg
il formé aussi et c'est comme ça qu'ils
sont rentrés dans la vidé des Français
ils formit un couple
mythique français ouai un couple
mythique peut-être un franco-britannique
francobritannique mais peut-être je
crois qu'on va arriver jeanh ganglad il
me semble un couple mythique et un
couple un des premiers cloupes qui s'est
autant mis en scène et qui l'a fait
volontiers il jouait avec la presse avec
les médias qui conviait chez eux rue de
Verneuil je pense qu'ils étaient
tellement heureux enfin c'est
l'interprétation que j'en ai et amour
était tellement beau et tell il se ils
se prêtaient volontiers une certaine
mise en scène de leur amour parce que je
pense que ça les amusait que du coup on
ils ouvraient les portes de leur amour
alors c'est la version c'est en tout cas
la facette euh visible de l'iceberg on
sait que ça a été aussi une histoire
douloureuse que lui plus les années ont
passé plus il a été très dur avec elle
il l'a dit ensuite il s'en est pas caché
il a été violent verbalement
physiquement ça a été il y a eu aussi
des moments difficiles qui vont euh la
pousser elle à le quitter
mais c'est vrai que ça
reste emblématique d'une histoire
d'amour passionnelle
magnifique physiquement ils étaient
beaux vraiment à voir tous les deux on
voit les photos d'aujourd'hui et puis
leur fille Charlot ginsbourg qui qui
continue qui poursuit en fait tout ça
aujourd'hui et continue à incarner ce
mélange de de décontraction et de de de
d'élégance à la française voilà et sans
et en en arrivant à le faire avec les
caméras chez eux comme vous disiez qui
sans sans que ce soit euh de du tout euh
euh un problème pour revenir un peu sur
sa carrière C cinématographique euh il y
a ce film ensuite euh la moutarde me
montonné avec Pierre Richard qui signe
un peu son entrée dans le cinéma grand
public on va dire ouais ouais ouais
parce que jusqu'ici tous les films
qu'elle a fait on pas B il y a la
piscine bien sûr qui a un énorme succès
mais euh par exemple le film qu'elle a
fait avec Serge ginbourg mais jeetai moi
non plus euh n'a pas été euh un succès
commercial en en fait quand elle
commence à faire ses films de Claude
Zidi avec Pierre Richard on découvre
quelque chose auquel on ne s'attendait
peut-être pas c'est au potentiel comique
de Jan Birkin c'est quand même une
Anglaise un peu fragile avec cet accent
improbable une figure de la mode c'est
l'élégant c'est la c'est c'est c'est la
la petite chose comme ça un peu jolie un
peu troublante et au côté de Pierre
Richard est quand même un énorme acteur
comique on découvre un potentiel elle
elle a le sens du rythme elle a le sens
de de la répartie en tout cas
elle sait mais
parfaitement lancer la bonne répartie
son accent joue beaucoup aussi elle sait
en s'appropriant comme ça des
expressions françaises j'ai revu la
moutarde mon mononé il y a pas longtemps
cette façon qu'elle a de dire did donc
avec cet accent anglais c'est une
expression typiquement française elle la
transforme complètement c'est a un effet
comique incroyable mais encore jamais
ridicule et elle est elle est fabuleuse
vraiment c'est c'est fou d'arriver à
garder cette accent anglais alors j'ai
eu des interview de de personnes qui
disaient oui mais au début je pensais
qu'elle faisait exprès de le garder dans
la vie ça ça allit en fait non elle elle
a toujours finalement gardé clé
finalement ouais c'est en ça que je dis
je pense qu'elle a vraiment c'est
presque elle a elle a dépassé la langue
anglaise et la langue française elle a
inventé sa propre langue j'ai lu un
article il y a pas longtemps sur
justement les néologismes qu'elle avait
inventé le fait qu'il y a pas de genre
sur les noms en en anglais faisait
qu'elle elle elle elle se trompait dans
les genres en français un un table ou je
sais pas je je je sais jeis je n'aurais
pas la prétention de de dire une des
fautes qu'elle faisait mais du coup ces
fautes n'en étaient plus elle elle
s'était appropriée la langue française
pour en faire vraiment la langue de Jan
Birkin et de la même manière qu'elle a
creusé une place qui n'appartient qu'à
elle dans la culture française elle a
creusé comme ça une langue qui
n'appartient à qu'à elle un vocabulaire
une grammaire qui n'appartenait qu'à
elle dans la langue française jeis qu'on
parle aussi d'un autre film vous en
avvez parlé rapidement tout à l'heure
c'est en 1976 elle sort je t'aime moi
non plus elle est actrice sur un film de
c'est un film de de de Serge grinbourg
et et là elle se enfin
le film n'est pas tant un succès public
que ça mais mais par contre elle est
très marquante dedans oui elle est très
marquante parce que déjà enfin c'est
important pour une actrice elle s'est
coupé les cheveux elle a un look comme
ça qui fait vraiment ressortir son
androgynie elle joue le rôle d'une
sererveuse qui est prise dans un tri
angleamoureux avec qui tombe amourux
d'un homosexuel un camineur je
crois c'est un film qui fait scandale
parce que très sexuel très sensuel mais
là encore une fois elle ce qu'on voilà
le film est pas un succès mais ce qu'on
retient c'est cette image ce style elle
impose ce style cheveux courts euh mine
un peu
chionné toujours quelque chose de très
mélancolique on n pas parlé de ça mais
il y avait toujours elle portait la
mélancolie là encore avec une une
élégance incroyable et donc voilà je t'
moi non plus le débardeur le Marcel le
jean chifoné euh qui qui était
complètement captivant oui habillé pour
pour l'époque c'est c'est c'est c'était
cétait assez spécial de de voir ça aussi
disz oui oui oui puis parce que alors
j'ai pas vraiment de de souvenir du film
mais je pense qu'en terme d'image de la
femme dans les années 70 on avait une
image on il y avait l'image peut-être
très Hipi très libérée robe à fleur un
peu comme ça et l'image très
sophistiquée le disco va arriver enfin
on on est dans des choses on est à la
fois dans le cheveux fou le cheveux très
bruchés elle elle arrive elle a les
cheveux court
et et voilà et cette androgénie elle est
complètement à contre courant de du
style de l'époque on va continuer sur sa
sur sa vie personnelle on disait elle
vit après une rupture avec avec Serge
ginbourg d'ailleurs elle a beaucoup été
vu comme la muse de SGE ginbourg comme
sa chose et finalement on s'est rendu
compte que pas vraiment pas du tout pas
du tout elle était oui elle l'a inspiré
mais elle a elle a une partie prenante
dans ses chansons dans les chansons
qu'elle a chanté dans dans dans dans le
travail qu'ils ont fait tous les deux
les chansons de ginbourg qu'elle a
chanté enfin ça aurait jamais été la
même chose sans sa voix sans son
interprétation sans cet accent
sans tout le vécu qu'elle a met quand
elle chante Babylon et Babylone c'est
justement toute cette mélancolie qui lui
colle à la peau depuis qu'elle est
enfant enfin il y a eu des brisures on
les connaît pas toutes mais c'est
quelque chose qu'elle a toujours porté
en elle comme ça cette cette fragilité
cette fure et et c'est il n'y a qu'elle
qui peut apporter ça du coup elle
co-crée les chansons de ginsbourg elle
n'est pas juste l'amuse elle est
vraiment la co-créatrice de ces chansons
et donc on va arriver sur leur sur leur
rupture ils vont continuer à travailler
ensemble mais il y a il y a cette
rupture et
forcément la France perd un de ses
couples mythiques on va dire ouais ouais
la France perd un de ses couples
mythiques il gagne quand même un album
fabuleux donc Babylon in Babylon ils ils
arriveront même on on va
arriverinouchon ouais ouais qui éit un
de ceux qui lui a rendu un des premiers
hommages quand elle est décédé le le
weekend dernier le weekend
dernier c'est marrant je vois et je
pense voilà un autre un autre personnage
emblématique de la culture française qui
incarne justement cette cette fragilité
très élégante je pense qu'ils avaient ça
en commun tous les deux mais donc oui
ils rompent ils arrivent à sublimer leur
amour même dans la rupture avec cet
album
euh il ils seront ils seront liés à
jamais h mais elle elle part parce
qu'elle est malheureuse parce que ça
devient trop difficile parce que
gansbour devient une caricature de
lui-même et elle fait ce que beaucoup de
femmes font aujourd'hui enfin la ce qui
est toujours voilà ce qui ce qui est un
geste courageux difficile elle le fait
et elle le fait par avec sa fille sous
le bras parce que je pense qu'elle sait
aussi qu'elle qu'elle existe par
elle-même enfin qu'elle n'a pas besoin
de lui pour pour exister ensuite pour
exister effectivement elle rencontre
ensuite Jacques Doyon le le qui va
tourner un film et là aussi une autre
histoire d'amour va commencer à ce
momentou autre histoire d'amour commence
moins moin sous les sous les projecteurs
même SII est un est un grand réalisateur
très connu et qui a c beaucoup decès
euh mais c'est une autre une autre
personnalité qui arrive à ce moment-là
c'est les années 80 alors une fille
aussi avec lui ludoyon qu'on connaît
bien sûr euh elle
ne elle ne sort pas pour autant de des
projecteur de la lumière elle va
continuer à faire des albums euh elle se
réinvente à chaque fois h effectivement
lou d'on qui lu avait rendu un vibrant
hommage lors des Victoires de la Musique
effectivement euh on peut parler aussi
de de de ces de ses engagements
militants Jane Birkin était une
militante alors quand elle était plus
jeune elle disait qu'elle voulait pas
prendre parti parce qu'elle été vu comme
quelqu'un de frivole et qu'elle voulait
pas que les sujets soi soi associés à ça
mais après elle en a beaucoup fait aussi
pour beaucoup Edie de préo ouais elle en
a elle l'a beaucoup fait elle a commencé
je crois c'était on il y a eu le
procès contre le procès de cette femme
qui avait qui avait subi un avortement
elle s'est mobilisé pour ça euh c'était
dans les années 60 je crois très jeune
quand même c'était une prise de parole
audacieuse à l'époque féministe donc
qu'elle a elle a première fois qu'elle
est apparue ensuite on l'a vu se
mobiliser beaucoup pour les sans papiers
euh on l'a vu se mobiliser pour les
malades du SIDA on l'a vu se mobilisé
pour la cause LGBT h et je crois avoir
lu dans une interview voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui au bout d'un moment
peut-être que à ses début elle disait
moi je ne peux pas prendre position j'ai
cette image comme ça très naïf très
fragile ça ne me va pas mais elle elle a
vite changé d' viis mais je crois
qu'elle l'a toujours fait de manière
très très naturelle elle voyait une
injustice elle voyait quelque chose
n'allait pas en fait dans l'harmonie du
monde euh bah elle elle elle elle
prenait la défense de de ceux qui
subissaient des injustices et ça lui
paraissait très naturel c'est ça lu
paraissait complètement normal euh il y
a il y a il y a aussi un peut-être une
grande date aussi dans dans dans dans sa
vie c'est le 2 mars 91 où elle va perdre
ensuite Serge ginsbourg là aussi on
imagine que c'est voilà elle perd
finalement son son son compagnon de
toujours même s'ils ont pas resté
ensemble si longtemps que çaou ouais non
non c'est un cataclysme c'est un
cataclysme aussi pour sa fille au char
de ginsbourg c'est un cataclisme mais
ils resteront toujours liés elle a al je
n'ai plus les titres en tête mais elle a
enregistrait des disques ensuite de
chanson de ginbourg il y a quelques
années encore il y a pas si longtemps
elle elle se produisait sur scène avec
un orchestre symphonique où elle
reprenait les chansons de ginbourg moi
j'ai eu la chance de l'avoir en concert
à cette époque- làà je me souviens de
l'incroyable grâce qu'elle dégageait sur
scène c'était bizarrement c'est la
première fois que je la voyais j'avais
beau connaître les images j'avais beau
avoir entendu les chansons des centaines
de fois la voir sur scène c'était
incroyable c'était incroyable alors que
je pense que voilà corère devrait
devrait peut-être arriver d'ici quelques
instants c'est un taxi qui qui
arrive j Birkin finalement aura réussi à
garder toute sa vie une espèce de de
fraîcheur de vivre et c'est c'est à ça
qu'on qu'on la reconnaît qu'elle va
qu'elle est très importante pour nous
ouais une fraîchure de vivre sans être
pourtant une c'est chez là je crois
dirait j'ai bien l'impression oui ouais
euh oui sans être pour autant une une
Hollywood girl euh
ouais
elle c'était euh on arrive même pas à la
qualifier en fait on c'était aussi une
une une mère parce qu'on la connaît
aussi en tant que mère de de trois
filles on peut pas non plus se projeter
le public ne pas se se projeter lui-même
dans cette image là une amie c'est
encore autre chose par parce qu'elle
avait quand même cette distance qu'on
les stars euh les gens sentaient à la
fois proche d'elle et à la fois c'était
une icône comme ça c'est indéfinissable
le le le symbole qu'elle reste pour la
pour la pour la culture française moi je
pense qu'elle reste le le la preuve que
la culture française peut se
métamorphoser peut se nourrir d'autres
pays d'autres langues Catherine deu euh
et reste ainsi avec Kara mastrini et
Benjamin Biolet il me semble ouais que
la culture française en fait peut se
nourrir d'autres langues d'autres pays
d'autres cultures et je pense qu'elle
elle était peut-être le symbole de cette
culture française en perpétuelle
métamorphose qui qui bouge qui se nourit
de plein de choses qui peut être
finalement dynamité par une petite fille
qui arrive d'Angleterre qui ave gaz vous
par de sa mère de famille vu dans des
dans des images c'est c'est ces caméras
qui la suivait jusqu'en soirée derrière
puis après on l' voyé à 8h du matin pour
aller amener ses enfants à l'école c'est
ass incroyable c'est voilà c'est voilà
c'est aussi une image de la femme
qu'elle a construite qui est fait du
bien à beaucoup de femmes qui a inspiré
beaucoup de femmes cette liberté cette
cette joie cette force cette façon de
d'être de de montrer ses failles et ses
forces en même temps sans pour autant
les porter comme ça euh en B enfin comme
sans pour autant les revendiquer rester
toujours naturel
euh une certaine désinvolture enfin tout
ça était très inspirant pour beaucoup de
femmes très bien merci beaucoup
Pascaline d'avoir été avec nous les
internautes avent resté avec nous bien
évidemment on va continuer de de de de
suivre ces obsèques on va vous continuer
de vous les diffuser en tout cas vous
allez pouvoir suivre cette cérémonie je
crois que c chanteur M qui arrive
actuellement vous allez pouvoir
continuer de suivre ça merci à vous
restez avec
[Musique]
nous
ah oui quand
[Musique]
même C avec
avec avec de ouis avait sa
[Musique]
fille
ai
mar
par contre vous avez pas
[Musique]
vu
ça commence 10h on est
[Musique]
d'accord pas
ouais
[Musique]
allô
allô on bloque plus personne ne
[Musique]
passe
ouis bah oui ça y est ça
[Musique]
ouais bien s
regarde
[Musique]
d' pas mon
PAP a un petit trou
là ça fait chier
on on a qu'une
[Musique]
cheveur
waouh
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
de ONM 122m 122 la
personnalité dou
[Musique]
ouais
ouais c'est Cédric
euh
[Musique]
c'estiousès
très
[Musique]
non plus le C arriv alors beaucoup de
personn sont attendu il on pu voir
apercevoir Carole Bouquet encore José
Garcia ch aussi chez est là aussi ainsi
que
adamour vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
est accompagné de
benjaminé qui doit durers de 2h et d'ici
[Musique]
persones
cé alors là j'en sais rien est-ce que sa
Rob ne fait pas des j'en sais
rien oui mais enfin on peut à ce
momentlà on peutimer mais c'est vrai
que saint roc enterre quelque fois des
gens qui ne sont pas catholiques parce
que c'est l'église des
artistes faut dire
c'est son ch fait où estce que tu veux
mettre pour faire faire cérémonie
chez
non voilà ou
bien puis en plus je veux dire chez nous
les églises es sont belles elle est dans
un truc
magnifque
en il av l' un peu
B
j'aur l'ARM
[Musique]
a ah
ou
avec
[Musique]
coff
ou
[Musique]
d'accord
encore
[Musique]
ch
i
[Musique]
ah
avec ça
[Musique]
F
la
[Musique]
S
de je sais
[Musique]
pas ok super super
la
avec sa
fille
F
[Musique]
sont
minutens tout
l'heure
[Musique]
ou
et
HUG fr c ça
[Musique]
le
OK
[Musique]
dans
est
[Musique]
monter
sur
attention
ch
une
blague ah non mais c'est une
blague mais REC en
fait une
blague
tu as tu tu as une autre vue en hauteur
marine on a deux
caméras tu la
voisre extérieur s'il vous
plaît
mais non de
de oui alors il y aura
plus
le
grandmre
[Musique]
on
a
pas tarder
le
tu
dois
[Musique]
ahahah
encore encore
[Applaudissements]
enc
ch silence
monantage
[Musique]
ainsi tout homme qui croit en lui ne
périra pas mais il obtiendra la vie
éternelle
chère famille FAM chers amis je suis
heureux de vous accueillir d'abord la
révérende Alison
Lam qui vient d'Angleterre pour diriger
cette cérémonie comme l'a voulu la
définte et selon votre
volonté le révérend Marc Osborne qui est
recteur de l'église Saint-Georges à
Paris je salue tous ceux qui sont venus
rendre hommage c'est un élément
important
de la vie humaine d'accompagner jusqu'au
bout je salue Madame Brigitte Macron
bien entendu qui dit par sa présence
beaucoup de ce que j Berkin était pour
la France et ce qu'elle a fait pour elle
au-delà de l'amitié bien sûr que l'on
peut
avoir madame la ministre de la Culture
je suis heureux de vous
accueillir
Abd un peu CHEZ VOUS ICI c'est la
paroisse des artistes vous y avez donc
une place toute particulière je salue
Madame Anne duncen de l'ambassade
britannique monsieur Jérémy
potier son
excellence l'ambassadeur
Mokita qui est du Japon en France qui
dit toute l'amitié que Jane Berkin avait
pour votre pays aussi aimer un pays
c'est pouvoir en aimer plusieurs je
salue monsieur José pi le chef de
protocole de l'Élysée compagne madame
Macron Monsieur Jean treger et
Jean-François treger et Michel Treg je
salue tout le monde j'espère n'avoir
oublié personne que je devais citer mais
nous sommes surtout unis dans la prière
et l'amitié pour
elle
Charlotte lou
Andrew et toute la
famille
madame ladies and gentlemen il est mon
très grand honneur d'être invité par la
famille de J à officier ce service pour
elle comme vous le savez J d'origine
britannique et comme monsieur l'abbé a
dit elle a voulu que ce rite suive en
gros la tradition
anglicaine nous tenons à remercier
l'abbé Thierry pour son accueil si
généreux depuis de nombreuses années
l'église saintroc offire un ministère
spirituel de soutien et d'écoute pour la
comm unuté artistique de France il est
donc fort à propos que nous sommes
réunis dans ce lieu beau dramatique et
solonnel pour célébrer une vie si riche
engagé et
créateur
service
miure
[Musique]
je vous encourage à les joindre à
chanter avec enthousiasme même comme
vous pouvez Jane l'aurait apprécié qu'on
chante aujourd'hui j'en suis
sûre et maintenant j'invite le révérent
Marc à amener notre prière
d'ouverture nous sommes réunis tous
aujourd'hui devant Dieu pour nous
souvenir de
Jane pour rendre grâce pour sa vie pour
la remettre à Dieu et pour se
réconforter les uns les autres je vous
invite à prier avec
moi Dieu de toute consolation ton Fils
Jésus-Christ F bouleversé jusqu'aux
larmes au sépulcre de Lazar son ami
déverse ta compassion sur tes enfants
dans ce temps de deuil dans nos cœurs
troublés la lu de l'espérance et
fortifier en nous la foi par JésusChrist
notre Seigneur amen amen messieurs
mesames vez-vous
rester pour
[Musique]
notre
RB
[Musique]
the
ofous
[Musique]
on
jakaj
[Musique]
V
I in
presence
of
[Musique]
my
with
[Musique]
my
ch
[Musique]
z vous
asseoir j'invite Madame Catherine de
Neu
la vie est plus
vanue une image que l'ombre sur le
mur pourtant l'héroglyphe obscur qui
trace ton passage m'enchante et ton R
pareil au bclat des armes et jusqu'à ces
menteuse
larmes le
soleil mourir non
plus la nuit quand tu as peur n'écoute
pas battre ton cœur c'est une
étrange
[Applaudissements]
avec le
chagrin j'ai fait confiance au
[Musique]
m un choix qui m'a été évident depuis
dimanche
dernier je remercie mon père d'avoir
tant aimé ma
mère je remercie ma mère de l'avoir tant
aimé
aussi je me retrouve
orveline je vois toutes vos âmes en
peine sans
elle je vois déjà le vide qu'elle nous
laisse c'est ma maman c'est notre
maman sa
Jeanette votre
J
signalement yeux
bleu
cheveux
châtin
[Musique]
JP
anglaise de sexe féminin
âge entre 20 et
apprends le dessin
domicilier chez ses parents yeux
bleu
chemin
jadin j
[Musique]
p le nez
à por disparu ce
matin à
5h
200 yeux bleus
cheveux
j'attend
jy tu dors au bord du
[Musique]
chamaon une fleur de sang à la
main
[Applaudissements]
petit
inventaire il y a toi 7 ans peut-être
avec la casquette militaire de ton père
sur le radeau Linda pour un magazine il
y a toi au côté de ton père fier quand
il retourne sur les côtes breton
familière pendant la guerre toi qui nous
racontes job et sa torche le bout rouge
des cigarettes des soldats allemands il
y a Roman et moi avec le lapin le
buouldog à l'avant de la camionnette du
dépanneur qui rigole que tu ai pu penser
que la marie sans fenêtre tiendrait la
verre sur l'autoroute en plein hiver il
y a toi qui me demande de te rejoindre
sur la péniche avec 100 paires de
balerines pour les enfants que vous avez
rapatrier avec Ari moukin il y a toi qui
compte t fourmis qui Caval le long de
mes jambes sur la plage avec JAC Perin
avant de suivre les beau people il y a
toi qui me fout la trouille en partant à
s sous les bombes parce que tu dis que
j'aurais honte plus tard que ma mère a
rien fait il y a toi qui nous laisse
roman et moi courir à moitié à poil dans
le bois de Boulogne déguisé en indien à
la fu des pervers disant que ça leur
foutra la trouille et que ça leur
apprendra la leçon
laquelle il y a toi qui nous traînne le
dimanche avec les poupoules que tu veut
qu'on distribue à joli cœur qui en veut
pas qui préférait son coup de Ja il y a
toi qui monte sur la la moto pays de Gal
qui démarre sans avoir demandé à Andr
sont les freins et qui t'écrase contre
le mur la jambe cassée de tordant de
douleur et de rire dans les bras de ton
frère il y a le diamant que tu as
balancé par une advertance dans une
boîte de l'exo dans la poubelle de ta
chambre de la tour et qu'on retrouve des
années plus tard en Bretagne car tu
avais oublié de vier les poubelles mis
tel qu au déménagement il y B qui sort
d'une boîte offerte par JA l'htel ni
puis a Dora il a et enfin petite B il y
Atig avant la nee pour arriver chez ton
frère les grands dîners et mes
aller-retours à la dernière goutte il y
a b et toi devenu Bob and Jim dans la
caravane traversant les États-Unis avec
anno et Ned il y a toi qui me mets sur
ton grand mentau pour que je conduise
toute seule la route de Death Valley et
moi qui te dis que mes jambes sont trop
courtes pour toucher les pédales et voir
la route en même temps et toi qui me
réponds tranquillement que tu me fais
confiance et qui t'endor il y a
Charlotte et moi que t'envoie dans une
réserve indienne la nuit car on est
encore une fois tombé en panne pour
qu'il nous prête un petit pille il y a
Marl t'a GG qui court sur la plage de
Sainte Marguerite il y a Charlotte et
Lola sur le capot de la voiture à
criseveuil il y a papi qui se casse la
gueule au sport d'hiver et le lendemain
ta mère et toi qui nous quitte dans
l'ambulance entre les deux brancards il
y a Ann Henry Jo Jack enrôleur à
pratarkum faisant tomber le sapin il y a
lenda et Mike à par pour ce Noël avec
enceinte de roman il y a toi à
mettant un faux œil dans le T de papi
qui le boit d'un trait toi qui me
regarde honteuse et qui panique moi qui
éclate en sanglot et lui qui finalement
sourit et ouvre doucement sa paume avec
l'œil intact il y a Lola que tu tiens
dans tes bras enceinte de moi il y a toi
dans la voiture quand je t'annonce pour
quête il y a Jacques qui term qui dans n
PUL Jacques qui part en avance à
l'aéroport parce qu'on arrive toujours
en retard pour prendre l'avion qui nous
attendra comme tu dis et c'était S en
vrai il y a agè qui nous embarque en
camionnette dans une maison d'enfance
dont elle a pas les clés vous deux me
faisant la courte échelle pour que je
puisse me faufiler par la petite fenêtre
en premier en me faisant des signes des
choses que vous voulez que je prenne en
me disant qu'on joue à orlev West il y a
NAD NAD et ses comic book il y a Serge
qui fait le cowboy et les Indiens sur le
piano de la tour pendant que Lulu dort
sur le canapé il y a Charlotte qu'on va
voir sur ses premiers tournages et toi
qui la regarde si fierre disant qu'elle
est encore toute petite mais que c'est
déjà une grande actrice il y a toi avec
quel bébé dans les bras à l'hôtel
Esmeralda il y a la loge du splendide où
je joue avec les poulets en plastique il
y a la loge avec ardityti où je déguise
roman en petite dame qui se trompe de
pores cherchant les chiottes et qui
déboule sur scène il y a la loge du
Casino de Paris avec Philippe Le Richon
et toi qui as si peur à chaque fois de
monter sur scène il y a dada qui me
tient la pince qui me met sur ses
épaules pour fendre la foule il y a toi
qui me fait pleurer en chantant my
little girl de carousel en traversant le
Lincoln Square Park dans un New York
coup gorge début 80 et ce taximan qui
nous supplie de rentrer dans son taxi
gratuitement car il veut pas de nos mort
sur la conscience et toi que ça amuse
beaucoup et qui dit comme à chaque fois
cette phrase étrange would
dare il y a toi cette sainte Valentin
bien triste qui me dit de pas manger les
bonbons en cœur du Chelsea Hotel
attention ma Loulou il doit y avoir du
drogue il y a toi la barboche enceinte
de 8 mois en train de recoure la tête de
ton pre père avec ton kit de couture il
s'est fendu la tête sur la porcelaine
des water closett il y a Romain et moi
que tu embarques sur la petite île au
lapin dans le bateau que Jacques t'a
acheté vite à regret car tu n'avais
peut-être pas hérité du pied marin de
ton père on avait fait le tour de l'île
et on l'avait retrouvé échoué au milieu
de la plage oh merde tuavais
dit tu avais oublié les maraes toi
encore une fois qui nous enroule dans
ton pull en tirant en l'air des fusées
de détresse il y a les sauveteurs en mer
qui arrivent et nous sauvent encore une
fois et qui a double titre je pense te
nomme marine il y avan siib sur le
bateau à la berbraque avec Charlotte
dans les bras il y a toi tenant à peine
debout allons manifester encore une fois
pu rapatrié en urgence à la maison
encore une fois ton bras qui te fait mal
et on rigole car on a oublié si c'est le
gauche ou si c'est le droit qui est
mauvais signe il y a moi le jour de mon
accouchement avec toi qui not au feu sur
ton bras les contractions et quand on
arrive à l'hôpital avec John tu montres
aux infirmières hiéroglyp à moitié
effacé disant elle en est là il y a moi
qui t'ennuie souvent qui te demande à
être un peu plus raisonnable et quand on
dit avec Charlotte que c'est peut-être
pas raisonnable en plein chino d'aller
au plus près de
Fukushima il y a quête et toi qui
escalade les grilles d'un jardin en
Angleterre il y a toi qui dessine les
hippopotames en Afrique avec roman il y
a toi qui dessine les filles en vitrine
en Belgique et qui me demande de glisser
les dessins sous la porte et elle ravie
qui te lance des bais
il y a nous courant à Kyoto derrière
leschat toi voulant qu'elle me maquille
la dame Auster qui nous arrête mais qui
V sous ton char nous laisse rentrer en
catiniie il y a toi dans la ren 5
couvert de stickers touche pas à mon
pote la banquette arrière couverte de
Gou allant de maison de retraite en
maison de retraite et nous demandant
avec roman de faire croire qu'on va voir
nos
grands-parents pour pouvoir passer du
temps avec des petits vieux qu'on
connait pas il a la dame que tu adoré
qui finissait jamais ses phrases il y a
tes dîners les dis proportions des
proportions qure canards pour si
invités il y a des trompeleil de trous
de souris et toile d'araignée que tu
dessines au mur de tes
maisons il y a toi qui fait rire Souchon
en mettant sur ton répondeur que tu es
épuisé parce que tu repètes matin midi
et soir il y a petit David que tu prends
sous ton aile à la mort de ta mère il y
a petit Michel fidèle dans les couloirs
d'avissen dans tous les théâtres il y a
ben et sa peau qui cavalent dans la
véranda il y a Marlot et Alice de tout
tes mauvais coups qui piqueniquent sous
la sculpture de la vache place fustinber
en pleine nuit il y a Charlotte et quê
dans cette maison louée au pays de Gal
pleurant de rire cherchant à voir qui a
les genoux qui touchent il y a toi qui
va voir mimi toi qui Vaas voir
Jacqueline toi qui Vaas voir Yvette
toujours sans faute il y a Gabriel et
toi radieuse petites anglaises soudées
depuis 50 ans de toutes les aventures de
toutes les bêtises et de tous les
drames il y a toi robe rouge pied nu qui
fait tourner les têtes et les scènes du
monde entier il y a Nellie que tu appel
je les derniers mois il y a P que je te
lise comme tu le disisais à papi il y a
Stéphane qui te raconte CROUS toi yeux
fermés qui sourit il y a Joe qui frappe
à la fenêtre en route pour l'école pour
te dire love il y a lazel ton petit peuf
que tu laisses jouer avec le câble à
oxygène en disant que ça serait une
drôle de FA
il y a toi qui a dit que tu ferais la
course avec lui à qui il serait le
premier debout pour marcher et c'est toi
qui a
gagné toi qui debout et forte de nouveau
pour le mariage de Ben brave en tout
avec ta canne et Marl et Romain au bras
il y a tes sa que tu trouves si douce il
y a toi qui meurt et qui revit encore
une fois et encore une fois qui te lève
si fragile au soins intensifs pour Sever
ta reine il y a toi qui dit paf paf paf
est-ce qu'on fait te rapporter un an il
y a tous tes dessins de nous sur tes
boîtes oranges il y a la version des
trois petits
cochons il y a gus qui boî et que tu
appelles ton Oracle il y a je il y a
my qui est dans ma tête en boucle depuis
dimanche il y a les lettes d'amour de
jacqu entouré d'un rument rouge que j'ai
trouvé près de ton lit il y a ton mot
près du mien Malou Sentinel
il y a toi qui faisait passer tout le
monde avant toi et des fois avant nous
et des fois ça nous fait chier toi qui
aimis ton public plus que tout plus que
tout toi qui appelles Olivier pour
demander les dates de l'Olympia et a
Charlotte et man près de toi une
dernière
fois
maman merci pour toutes ces aventures
merci de pas avoir été ordinaire
raisonnable ou
docile ce monde de
demain bien paisible et raisonné ça
m'emmerde
déjà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mar
S
[Musique]
avec son sens de la formule Jane disait
qu'on s'était connu dans un
tank c'était vrai même si ce n'était pas
exactement un tank mais un transport
blindé sur les chemins menant à sarev en
1995 on sétait quand même aperçu avant
le départ l'ami qui nous menait là-bas
Francis be nous avait réuni au bar du
luutia
me dira plus tard qu'elle avait pensé ce
type doit être un intellectuel mondain
il n'ira
pas et moi de mon côté je m'était dit
qu'elle était une star probablement un
peu futile qu'elle renoncerait au
dernier moment mais si elle était partie
ce n'était pas son genre de s'engager à
moitié mais je ne le savais pas encore
et là-bas dans la ville assiégée
bombardé j'ai été tout de suite
ébloui
par sa beauté si évidente et simple bien
sûr si éclatante et sans
apprês je n'étais pas le seul tous les
soldats français étaient amoureux
d'elle mais aussi par son esprit par
l'intention passionnée qu'elle portait
aux gens par le calme avec lequel elle
affrontait les situations d'une ville en
guerre comme si elle avait toujours vécu
dans le
danger avec cette vertu qu'on prête un
juste titre à l'Angleterre du BL
c'est la nuit sur une colline on devine
vaguement la ville en dessous tout feu
éteint dans une
demi-brume on enterre un homme tué par
un éclat d'bu on enterre la nuit par
peur des snipers l'imam sal maudit dans
l'ombre des petites lumières volent
entre les tombes ce sont des lucioles ou
des
âmes le mort est descendu dans la fusse
couvert d'un simple sphère très blanc
dans cette
obscurité soudain elle se joint aux
hommes qui l'enterrent qui ne la
connaissent pas à genoux elle pousse
avec eux la terre de ses
mains un geste d'une beauté
parfaite absolument simple et absolument
audacieux à son
image un geste comme issu de la tragédie
antique
elle vient de jouer andromac dans les
trroisenes de ripide au National Theater
à
Londres telle je la vois pour toujours
tranquillement belle attentive au
malheur
intrépide je cherche des anecdotes je
n'en trouve pas que je nai déjà dit ou
bien alors trop insignifiante ou trop
personnelle je cherche une anecdote pour
faire sourire je sais que c'est l'usage
dans ces cérémonie d'adieu ce sourire à
travers les larmes qui est justement
celui
d'andromac et je n'en trouve pas si
celle-ci peut-être on est à Sana au
Yémen en 1996 où un autre ami nous a
mené sur les traces de rimbau on est à
l'hôtel sans y prendre regardarde elle
se change devant une grande fenêtre qui
donne sur une rue populeuse de Sana
horrifiée je la pousse au fond de la
chambre elle se moque de moi me trouve
poltron et pu bon elle n'a peut-être pas
d' mais pour une fois je crois avoir un
peu raison quand même le Yémen n'est pas
le genre de pays où on est tellement fan
des de
souchic mais au fond ce ne sont pas des
anecdotes que je veux égraner
aujourd'hui nous ressentons tous chacun
à sa façon combien son absence va nous
appauvrir je voudrais dire que ces jours
derniers seulement j'ai pu nommer un
sentiment que j'éprouvé pour
J au-delà de l'immense affection qui
avait doucement
pas toujours
doucement succéder aux amours
anciens et ce sentiment c'est
l'admiration c'est peut-être un peu
solennel c'est sûrement en tout cas ce
qu'elle aurait pensé elle qui détestait
tant les grands mots les grands
airs mais c'est comme ça et moi je
trouve que je suis bien bête d'avoir mis
si longtemps à mon
apercevoir nous venions d'histoire
complètement différentes et presque
opposé
et pourtant toutes les qualités que
j'avais toujours respecté sans les
cultiver assez moi-même je les découvrai
en
elle le courage je l'ai déjà dit dans le
danger mais aussi plus tard dans le
deuil et la
maladie avec le courage il n'y a qu'une
autre vertu vertu
cardinale qui est la bonté ce mot qui
fait rire les
sous et la bonté la petite bonté don les
grands écrivains
russes elle l'avait si inaltérable en
elle que même les gens qui ne la
connaissaient pas vous ne la connaissait
que de
loin la sentait et c'est cela je crois
qui explique l'énorme émotion qui s'est
manifesté depuis une
semaine lorsque je l'ai connu je me
souviens qu'elle passait des heures des
journées à s'occuper d'une vieille femme
quelque peu acariâtre qui la
tyrannisé moi qui ne fut pas aussi
généreux qu'elle je trouvais qu'elle
chariait et qu'elle a mise en scène bien
des années plus tard avec humour et
compassion et la touche d'extravagance
qu'elle avait dans son film boxuse c'est
an Girardo qui
l'incarne Gabriel me raconte qu'une
femme de ménage à l'hôpital lui a dit ne
mourrez pas Madame la France a besoin de
vous comme elle avait raison cette femme
nous avons je ne parle même pas de la
France nous avons besoin de sa
générosité je n'ai jamais connu
quelqu'un d'I généreux
que dans tous les sens ce mot depuis les
plus
simples les plus triviaux le fric et
tout ça jusqu'au plus
raffiné la disposition à se passionner
pour les autres à se réjouir de leur
succès à être indulgent à leur défaut et
elle en a eu bien besoin avec
moi une femme une
fois une fois chez les amis parce que
j'avais dû le mériter elle m'a quand
même balancé un verre de vin au visage
ajoutant en rant qu'elle regrettait de
ne pas m'avoir envoyer tout le contenu
de la
bouteille comme je voudrais le reprendre
encore dans la gueule ce ver
elle était
irrésistible même dans la
colère
car il n'y avait en elle rien qui pèse
ou qui pose elle n'était Dieu sait ni
Joh of Ark ni Florence
Nightingale tout en elle au contraire
était léger élégant gracieux musical
mais alors plutôt hrixati que
Wagner il y avait son merveilleux humour
et même cet allent de
clown son anticonformisme spontané sa
vivacité
sa constante curiosité intellectuelle sa
passion pour la
littérature à l'hôpital lisait la
recherche et se délectait de la façon
dont prou se moque du snobisme de le
Grandin le snobisme voilà bien un
sentiment si on peut appeler ça un
sentiment qui lui était plus
complètement étranger qu' aucune autre
personne que j'ai connu moi y
compris c'est que je dois d'avoir lu
gram Green et Dickel qu'il trouvait si
drôle et je ne la croyais pas mais elle
avait
raison c'est avec elle et Judy la reine
m que j'ai connu à Rome la maison de
kits et
ch sa gaieté était un té de
mélancolie et je m'en voudrais le temps
qui me reste à vivre d'avoir été parfois
celui par qui la mélancolie est venue
nous avions le même âge et il nous était
arrivé de nous dire qu'un jour nous
reprendrions la route commencée il y a
28 ans à
sarevo nous vieillirons
ensemble je serai seulement pour elle la
combattante la
valeureuse cet
hommevoque les mot du grand poète César
B
de la
[Musique]
la à la fin de la
bataille est morte la
combattante un homme vint à elle et lui
dit ne meurs pas je
t'aime
ma rencontre avec Jane eu lieu grâce à
mon ami Philippe lurichum l'homme de
l'ombre dans la carrière de Serge et de
Jane leur directeur artistique leur ami
mon ami j'ai vu tous ces concerts depuis
ses début au Bataclan jusqu'à mars 2002
où j présente arabesse côté à de l'Odéon
tu es un véritable choc un de ses plus
beaux concerts jeun est belle rayonnante
envoûtante pleine d'humour elle chante
comme une reine plus émouvante que
jamais j'envoie alors un petit mot à
philiip pour lui faire part de mon
ressenti pour lui dire combien j'ai aimé
et Philippe me répond je voudrais
déjeuner avec toi je ne la connaissais
pas elle venait souvent voir les
concerts des autres artistes avec qui je
travaille mais on ne se connaissait pas
ne s'était jamais parlé quelques jours
plus tard j'arrive au rendez-vous chez
vagenand boulevard Saint-Germain la
cantine de l'époque elle me tutoie
immédiatement et dès la fin du déjeuner
sa décision est prise je deviens son
tructeur et elle me dit en plus je n'ai
jamais eu de manager donc tu seras aussi
mon manager j'attaque avec la tournée
arabesque le projet par en flèche 350000
albums vendu et plus de 400 concerts
dans 47 pays pendant 4 ans je la suis
beaucoup enentourné je découvre une
femme à la fois profonde infiniment
drôle parfois très farfelu et une
générosité rare Jean et moi formons un
parfait bino on a des tas de points
communs d'affinité de mêmes engagements
humanitaires ou politiques la tournée
d'arabesque inclu le Proche Orient on
présente la même semaine le spectacle à
téavive puis à ramala bethleéem Gaza
partout là-bas tout le monde connaissait
gè et l'adorait tout est permis à Jen
mais pas dans la bande de Gaza on ne
connaissait pas j dans la bande de Gaza
il n'y avait pas de télévision on
demande à J de tronquer sa belle robe
rouge si légère qu'elle apparaît comme
dénudé et de remplacer par une chemise à
col Mao et on explique dit qu'il est
préférable de ne pas embrasser les
musiciens comme la coutume de le faire
en arrivant sur scène Jane entre en
scène au premier rang les dirigeants de
l'autorité palestinen du Hamas bonjour
on m'a dit qu'il ne fallait pas que
j'embrasse les musiciens alors je vais
juste leur embrasser les mains parce
qu'avant de chanter moi j'ai besoin de
la baiser elle l'a dit simplement sans
agressivité et les gens ont bien réagi
la spontanéité de jene brise bien des
barrières avec j'ai aussi découvert un
clan celui des ginbourg Birk d'Yon une
tribu que je me suis aimé comme une
famille j'aime les familles merveilleuse
fascinante famille lou Charlotte vous
êtes des êtres rares et tout comme quê
vous avez su donner tellement d'amour à
chaque heur de chaque jour le réservoir
était plein de carburant
entre J et moi il a eu l'amour de la
musique mais aussi la défense des causes
communes je pense notamment à anuki je a
mené un véritable combat en sa faveur et
je l'ai évidemment épaulé nous avons
pris rendez-vous et sommes allés
ensemble voir le président Sar ai pour
tenter de faire fermer les usines
totales en Birmanie jamais à cour d'idée
jene et plus son canal d'adresse s réuni
place de l'Hôtel de Ville tous les gens
qu'elle connaî pour une veillée hommage
àonguki tous ses amis sont là sont venus
une bougie à la main vous Catherine de
neuve Bernard laviler Charles Berling
toi Charlotte tramping Charles Berling
et tant d'autres Michel picoli Marion
ctillar ETCA tous réunis devant le
portrait de l'héroïne birman que
Bertrand de laané fait suspendre au murs
de la
les images sont relayées dans le monde
entier de façon virale la popularité de
gè est phénoménale et
mondiale j'ai traversé avec je des
périodes fantastiques des instants
magiques et des drames à plusieurs
reprises elle a été malade je l'ai
accompagné comme jeaurais fait pour un
membre de ma famille J a toujours voulu
continuer à chanter malgré les
souffrances multiples et variées alors
on s'est adapté on a essayé de gérer je
toujours relevé de sa première leucémie
au dommages collatéraux qui ont suivi et
puis l'insoutenable en 2013 la mort de
CL tout est fini pendant les 2 ans qui
ont suivi je la vois deux ou trois fois
par semaine et persiste à lui faire part
de toutes les demandes que je reçoit
dans l'espoir qu'un jour une petite
étincelle rallumera la flamme du désir
d'aimer de vivre de chanter durant cette
longue période de deuil les projets
continuent à affluer fin 2015 je reçois
un appel des Francopholies de Montréal
me proposant qu'en 2016 pour les 25 ans
de la mort de Serge j'êne face un
concert avec l'Orchestre symphonique de
Montréal au cours d'une de mes visites
je relat je cette proposition prête à
entendre un nom récurrent elle me dit je
vais le faire je reste bougeb pardon
elle dit oui Serge a tellement pompé les
airs classiques pour mes propres tubes
que je lui dois bien ça je vaux lui
prouver là-haut que je suis capable de
chanter avec un orcheste symphonique
pour les arrangements on engage le
génial Nobu Nobu yukin kajima il se met
au travail Philippe aussi se remet au
travail pour extraire de cet immense
répertoire les chansons les plus
adaptées à 75 musiciens classiques nobou
nous envoie des démos de ses
arrangements écoute après écoute le
visage de Jane s'éclaire elle sourit
reprend des forces je la vois renaêtre
sous mes yeux j'assiste à une lente et
salvatrice évolution je suis Amu je suis
heureux premier concert à Montréal un
moment unique qui restera gravé dans
dans nos mémoires une vraie merveille le
plus beau concert de Jan dirkin sur le
répertoire de Serge écrira Valérie leou
dans tél Rama dans l'avion du retour
Jeane rayonne cidéré par la réussite de
sa performance symphonique OL Olivier si
quelqu'un veut de nous avec ce spectacle
allons-y ça c'était toujours la phrase
de Jane si quelqu'un veut de moi si
quelqu'un veut de nous elle revit on
réalise une tournée mondiale de 75 dates
en 4 ans partout dans le monde incluant
le Carn guot de New York avec Rufus r
white en guest puis le bacon Theater en
2020 avec en invité les Américains
adorent les invités au concert toi
Charlotte et IgY pop je remercie Yan
Noel notre promoteur américain qui est
arrivé ce matin de New York pour être
avec nous pour ce dernier hommage à Jen
la réussite de ces concerts nous les
devons à toute son équipe surtout à toi
Christophe et à toi Stéphane vous l'avez
tellement bien entouré qu'elle a réussi
à tourner et Jess ton inébranlable
soutien à Jane au quotidien l'ont aidé à
surmonter tout ce qui auraiit pu
l'arrêter merci spécialement à vous
trois et puis la dernière étape chantter
avec toi ettienne je m'a dit tant de
fois être parvenu au champ du signe avec
le symphonique mais j'ai rien à perdre
et je tente toi qui a été si longtemps
l'amuse d'un homme ne pourrais-tu pas
pour une dernière petite aventure être
l'amuse d'un autre elle me répond mais
jamais tu plaisante et puis le lendemain
elle m'appelle elle me dit Olivier je te
connais tu as une idée derrière la tête
je dis ben oui
ettienne depuis le temps qu'Étienne te
parle de faire un album de haut Paron tu
dormais j c'est le moment et là elle me
répond mais tu es fou Étienne c'est
l'ami de la famille il a travaillé avec
Lou avec Charlotte il va tout de suite
imaginer que c'est un guetapan et puis
s'il refuse je seraiis vexé
publ les raisons pour refuser je dis
arrête je j'ai appelé Étienne il est
dans les starting block il attend ton
appel jeen l'appelle le travail commence
et c'est ainsi que na oh pardon tu
dormais une magnifique collaboration
d'écriture de coécriture de composition
de production entre un trio de choc
Étienne Jane et toi Jean-Louis Pierot le
disque est un énorme succès et Jane
reprend la route pour un nouveau concert
magnifique avec une équipe de tournée
brillante et puis en janvier le sublime
film Jane par Charlotte réalisé par toi
Charlotte une déclaration d'amour sans
images d'archive un travail intime
étonnant de franchise filmé sans
concession Jane dans le film dit c'est
dur de se voir vieillir mais il y a un
moment dans la vie où on y prête plus
attention quand est ce moment demande
Charlotte je pense que j'y arrive au
moment où on s'en fout répond gene ses
rides ses mains que Charlotte filme de
près n'enlève rien sa beauté à 75 ans
elle est magnifique fin aût 2021 un
nouveau drame je un AVC prie à temps
Gabriel toi la magnifique GAB tu été là
tu as réussi en réagissant si vite à
éviter que ce soit plus grave tu as été
son ange Gabriel depuis longtemps et là
encore Jane se relève peut-être trop tôt
elle décide de reprendre ses tournées
toujours depuis 16es ans que les
premiers problèmes sont arrivés Jane
s'est relevé et toujours grâce à la
bienveillance et au talent de son
bien-aimé le professeur Vincent Levi
relevé à la fois hyper fragile mais
guidé par une force intérieure que je
n'ai jamais vu chez qui que ce soit
d'autre autrees sauf ce 16 juillet 23
Jane est tombée elle ne s'est pas relevé
parmi les artistes qui ont changé ma vie
Jan Birkin a occupé une place capitale
bien au-delà de mon statut de producteur
et manager elle fut pendant plus de 20
ans une complice de tous les instant on
s'est appelé tous les jours elle a
dépassé la fréquence téléphonique de ma
mère et battre le record d'appel
téléphonique d'une mère juive ce n'est
pas
rien
[Applaudissements]
ch il y a 16 ans je vous ai rencontré un
matin dans le ha de l'hôpital
Saint-Louis un peu intimidé vre
impossible sac débordant de livres de
carnet de stylo vous avez souris et
votre première question avant même que
nous soyons dans le box de consultation
a été comment comment je peux aider vous
passz régulièrement à l'hôpital
patientant dans la salle d'attente avec
tous les autres malades ensuite il
fallait envoyer des communiqués de
presse qui RAC plus ou moins n'importe
quoi car onait vu JK à l'hôpital et puis
vous m'z suivi à Bob à l'hpital 93 et là
personne ne vous connaissa on pait même
prendre un café incognito dans la
caféria de l'hôpital ou même vous
hospitaliser en réanimation une jeune
étudiante en médecine vous demander si
vous aviez des enfants et quelle était
votre profession
chanteuse pour des raisons de
confidentialité je vous avais affublé du
nom de code Tarzan dans mon téléphone
qui est devenu votre surnom dans le
service lorsque beaucoup plus tard dans
un couloir lors d'un passage à l'hôpital
de jour vous l'avez appris vous avez
bien ri à
Avisen un matin nous avions besoin de la
vie d' collègue vous touffiez comme une
perdue ce collègue vous voyant entrer
dans son box a dû se rasseoir les yeux
brillants et bégillant souriant comme un
enfant qui rencontre son idole vous a
dit d'une voix tremblante d'émotion je
vous admire tellement avant de se
rasseoir de se ressaisir et de prendre
son
stéthoscope vous êtes venu plus souvent
à l'hôpital pour les traitements leur
cortège de complication souriante
inquiète de déranger de prendre la
chambre de quelqu'un qui en a le plus
besoin toujours avec votre impossible
sac qui m'inquiétait de plus en plus
tellement il déborda de carnet de livres
de pilu de comprimé et puis vos visites
à l'hôpital de jour dev régulière et pas
une fois veniez sans apporter à toute
l'équipe des macarons
des d'une hospitalisation alors que
j'étais désolé de vous annoncer que
vousz rester plusieurs semaines vous
m'avez dit vcent n'est pas un problème
j'ai commc à à la recher temps perdu je
vais tout
l CIT prou mais quelles que soi les
circonstances je ne vous ai jamais vu
qu'un livre à la main et vous étiez
impossible à arrêter nous avons appris
que l'on pouvait faire un concert de 3h
à ramala par 35 degrés et revenir à
l'hôpital avec une embolie pulmonaire et
repartir quelques semaines plus tard
pour le Canada ou le Japon vous
connaissiez les risques vous les
assumiez la douleur les contraintes les
complications vous les traversiez avec
un incroyable courage vous m'avez vous
nous avez ridiculisé auprès des
étudiants a déjoué tous les pronostics
avec la certitude que vous aviez de
pouvoir assurer le prochain concert
alors que vous étiez perfusé en secteur
stérile transfusé et sous-traitement et
vous aviez raison vous avez accepté de
tourner un petit film pour avisè lorsque
nous étions en compétition pour financer
un espace d'échange et de relâche et de
relaxation pour les patients vous avez
des confrères des collègues des
soignants vous avez organisé en toute
discrétion un concert pour l'hôpital il
y a encore quelques quelques mois vous
avez défendu le service public auquel
vous étiez tellement attachés je
pourrais ainsi continuer longtemps la
liste de ce que vous avez fait pour nous
tous mais surtout Jane nous avons tous
eu ce rare privilège de simplement
pouvoir passer du temps avec
vous vous me manquez terriblement depuis
le 16
juill
juste un petit mot pour ma
grand-mère mamie on aura fait 21 an
ensemble on aura fait plus de 21
conneries avec Alice avec Joe avec Ben
avec roman dans dans la maison à
pratarkum on sera échangé plus de plus
de 21 baisés toujours tendre avec moi
toujours tendre avec avec mon petit
frère lazelo que qui aura un an dans
dans 2 jours tellement tellement de de
moments où malgré tout ce que tu
représentes pour moi tu as été tu as été
comme voilà simplement ma ma petite
grand-mère où je me rappellerai des
histoires que tu me racontais des
grimaces que tu me faisais des des des
histoir de de tout ça je c'est un peu
désordonné parce que je nai j'ai pas
j'ai rien écrit mais voilà j'avais juste
envie de de dire ça et j'espère que de
làhaut tu tu tu nous regarderas tous et
qu'on pourra tous te te rendre F voà je
t'aime
[Applaudissements]
mie merci à
tous on va se lever maintenant pour
chanter comme on peut le Lim
[Musique]
Jérusalem
and
the of
[Musique]
God
was
[Musique]
Jerusalem
pr
[Musique]
my shall my soul SEP in my
heart till
[Musique]
weerusalem
a reading from Paul's first letter to
the Corinthians chapter
13 though I speak with the tonges of men
and of angels and have not love I am
become as sounding brass or a tinkling
symbol and though I have the gift of
prophecy and understand all mysteries
and all knowledge and though I have all
faith so that I could remove
mountains and have not love I am
nothing and though I bestow all my goods
to feed the Po and though I give my body
to be burnt and have not love it prof me
nothing love suffereth long and is
kind love envieth not love VTH not
itself is not puffed up do not behave
itself
unseenly seek not her
own is not easily provoked
think no
evil rejoiceth not in iniquity but
rejoiceth in the truth beareth All
Things believeth All Things hopeth All
Things
endureth All
Things love never
failth but whether there be prophecies
they shall fail
whether there be tonges they shall
cease whether there be knowledge it
shall vanish
away for we know in part and we prophesy
in
part but when that which is perfect is
come then that which is in part shall be
done
away when I was a child I speak as a
child I understood as a child I thought
as a child but when I became a man I put
away childish
things for now we see through a glass
darkly but then Face to
Face now I know in
part but then shall I know
even as I also I am
known and now abide faith hope love
these
three but the greatest of these is
love
une deuxème lecture qu'on a choisi pour
J du Cantique des
cantiquess mon bien-aimé me parle et il
me dit lève-toi mon ami VI donc ma toute
belle car l'hiver est passé et les
pluies ont cessé leur saison est finie
on voit des fleurs éclore à travers le
pays et le temps de chanter est
venu la voix des toururelles retentit
dans nos champs sur les figuers les
premiers fruits mûissent la vigne en
fleur exhale son
parfum lève-toi mon ami ma toute belle
et viens
oui viens avec
moi le Cantique des Cantiques est un
livre à part dans la Bible c'est le seul
qui soit consacré à la amour
romantique l'amour entre un roi et une
bergère mais il suffit de lire les
premières phrases pour se rendre compte
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un amour courtoi
il s'agit de l'amour
physique écoutez comment commence ce
livre ah que ta bouche me couvre de
baiser
et ça continue dans cette
veine il y a des passages
[Musique]
assezés dans la tradition juive le
cantique était considéré comme l'endroit
le plus sacré de l'écriture un rabin a
écrit toutes les écritures sont Saintes
mais le Cantique des cantiques et le
saint des
seints pourquoi lui donner tant de
prix et bien depuis les temps les plus
anciens on a compris que la le cantique
parlait de l'amour de Dieu pour son
peuple et pourtant on n trouve pas
beaucoup de l'amour dont parle la
première épitre aux Corinthiens la
l'amour patient plein de bonté de
gentillesse l'amour qui pardonne et se
donne dans le cantique tout parle du
désir insatiable qu'on les amons le leur
désir d'intimité physique de se
connaître l'un l'autre
entièrement ce qui nous dit c'est que
l'amour de Dieu n'est pas une affection
abstraite polie et
réservée comme celle d'un oncle
éloigné l'amour de Dieu est personnel et
passionné peut-être même
scandaleusement je t'aime dit Dieu oui
je
t'aime
comme beaucoup d'autres de ma génération
j'ai entendu parler de Jane burken pour
la première fois en
1969 quand le scandale de je t'aime moi
non plus a fait éruption dans une
Grande-Bretagne qui ne s'y attendait pas
j'ai dû l'entendre sur Radio Luxembourg
parce que bien entendu c'était exclu
pour le BBC trop Tor pour les Anglais
si les subtilités lyriques de la chanson
ont échappé aux autorités radiophoniques
elles ont certainement échappé aussi aux
adolescentes comme moi j'ai le souvenir
d'un cours de chimie où nous étions
agglutinés en faisant semblant
d'observer une expérience chimique et
riant comme des folles en essayant
d'imiter Serge et Jane
quand le prof nous a demandé ce que nous
faisions nous avons répondu que nous
pratiquions notre
français je n'ai jamais raconté cela à
Jane mais je crois qu'elle aurait bien
ri
aussi pendant les décennies qui ont
suivi 69 Jane n'était qu'une figure
abstraite pour moi jusqu'à ce qu'en
décembre 2013 elle m'a demandé en tant
que pasteur à ce moment-là de son église
anglicane à Paris d'officier au
funéraille de sa fille
Kate quand je l'ai rencontré j'ai été
frappé bien sûr par son charisme et son
charme physique mais surtout par sa
beauté
spirituelle chaleureuse et sans
prétention ce n'était ni l' star adulé
par les médias ni la PrimaDonna
elle n'était que qu'amitié
humilité humour et gentillesse
discrète une mère qui vivait un deuil
douloureux une femme qui avait beaucoup
aimé et dont le cœur s'était
brisé vulnérable et pourtant encore
tourné vers les les autres intéressés et
se souciant de même de moi qui venait
d'arriver à Paris
oui comme beaucoup d'entre nous ici moi
aussi j'ai bénéficié de l'hospitalité du
Grand cœur de
Jane plus tard est venu un temps de
parler autour d'une tasse de
thé de la vie et de la
mort de la p
de ce que que nous
aimons de la foi de
l'espérance et de
l'amour l'amour inaltérable du Dieu du
Cantique des Cantiques ce dieu amant ce
dieu
passionné désirant l'intimité absolue
avec ses créatures avec
nous et pas seulement le temps d'une
chanson
mais pour toute
éternité trouvons-nous cette idée de
Dieu
jeunante
scandaleuse nous ne devrions pas être
surpris quand nous regardons la croix de
Jésus car sur cette croix nous trouvons
ce même Dieu Celui qui nous a désiré au
point de mourir d'une telle
mort pour rendre
possible son union avec
nous pour nous pardonner de l'avoir
rejeté pour nous donner sa vie
abondante et pour remettre dans nos bras
tout ce que cette vie nous
dérobe
si si seulement nous acceptons don son
invitation au
voyage lève-toi
dit-il à chacun de nous mais
spécialement aujourd'hui à
Jane lève-toi mon amie ma toute belle et
viens
arise my darling my
beautiful
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'offrande que vous allez faire
maintenant servira à offrir des offices
ici et l'église de Saint-Georges
[Musique]
anglicane
aine și pr
cuvân
Mei ma
[Musique]
Koni
š
[Musique]
us
ipilisīosā
[Musique]
when we
shall
[Musique]
for
my
pu à
[Musique]
toi un temps de prière pour Jane pour la
famille et pour
nous-mêmes avant de prier je vous invite
à garder quelques moments de silence
pour vos propres pensées vos prières
vous sou vos
souvenirs peut-être vous avez un
souvenir spécial personnel de
Jane peut-être justetin merci pour le
cadeau de sa
vie peut-être il y a quelque chose que
vous auriez voulu lui dire mais il y
avait pas
l'opportunité Jésus
se
tient de chaque côté de la porte
entre la vie et la
mort nous nous pouvons lui confier
toutes ses pensées toutes nos soucis et
demander son aide il est à l'écoute donc
quelques moments de
silence
dieu de la
vie tu nous as fait un ton image pour
refléter ta vérité et ta lumière nous te
remerci pour Jane pour la grâce et la
miséricorde qu'elle a reçu de toi et
pour l'affection et l'amour que nous
avons reçu
d'elle tu as promis la vie éternelle à
ceux qui croient souviens-toi de Jane
comme nous aussi en gardant
mémoire conduis-la dans la plénitude de
ton Roya royaume
d'amour où les péchés sont à jamais
pardonnés et où la mort n'est plus grâce
à à ton Fils
Jésus-Christ
amen prions maintenant pour la famille
de
Jane gardons un tendre souvenir
aujourd'hui de Kate
aussi Dieu de toute
consolation tu transformes la douleur en
joie et la mort en vie dans ton amour
infini porte ton regard sur Charlotte et
loup et leurs proches leur
bien-aimés sur romon ben Marlot
Alice Joe
etelo et surtous ceux qui sont dans le
deuil dans les temps de ténèbres
donne-leur une fois patiante
fortifieles par l'expérience de ton
amour pour
eux sois leur soutien Seigneur et leur
paix au nom du Christ Prince de la Paix
nous
prions
amen et finalement quand nous perdons un
être
cherimé nous nous trouvons devant la
vérité qu'un jour chacun et chacune de
nous nous se tiendra devant
[Musique]
Dieu-même donc nous prions pour
nous Dieu tout-puissant tu as de la
tendresse pour tes enfants et ta
miséricorde sétend à toutes tes
œuvres guéris nos mémoires pour ce
qu'elle porte de blessures et
d'échec donne-nous la sagesse c'est la
grâce de faire bon usage du temps qui
nous est laissé sur cette terre et de
nous tourner vers le Christ de suivre
ses traces sur le chemin qui conduit à
la vie
éternel
AMEN
comme nous l'avons appris du Sauveur et
selon son commandement nous pouvons dire
avec confiance la prière des enfants de
Dieu notre Père qui est au
cux que ton nom soit sanctifié que ton
règne vienne que ta volonté soit faite
sur la terre comme au ciel donne-nous
aujourd'hui notre pain de ce jour
pardonne-nous nos offenses comme nous
pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensé et ne nous laisse pas entrer en
tentation mais délivre-nous du
mal nous voici
arrivés au seuil comme est arrivé au
seuil me entre dans le monde et la joie
éclate immédiatement en chaque enfant
une âme nous est retirée du monde et
c'est la tristesse qui séprend de notre
âme avant de dire le mot du dernier
adieu je vais reprendre celui de J mais
à
l'envers
DISP nous sommes appelés tous chacun par
notre nom à entrer dans ce chemin c'est
celui qui vous est proposé par cette
liturgie d'abord l'hommage humain que
vous avez fait d'elle et c'est d'une
grande
importance car nous devons garder
mémoire mais le chemin ne s'arrête pas
ici si nous l'avons porté jusqu'à
l'intérieur du temple
saint c'est la manifestation pas
seulement de notre amour c'est la
manifestation de la foi que nous avons
que nous pouvons cor la confié à Dieu
dans toute son humanité dans toute sa
corporéité elle est là et vous l'avez
évoqué vous avez dit que tous les
soldats français à un autre moment
étaient amoureux d'elle on pourrait
reprendre la même phrase en enlevant le
mot
soldat tous les Français étaient
amoureux d'elle parce qu'elle a fait
rayonner quelque chose de la gloire de
sa chanson par son propre sans jamais
cesser d'être si bien anglaise comme
vous me l'avez dit vous ces filles
jusqu'au dernier moment et peut-être de
plus en plus c'est pourquoi a voulu cet
attachement
indéfectible alors il ne nous reste plus
qu'une chose à faire c'est à
opérer le terrible jugement de Dieu
c'est celui que vous avez déjà opéré
c'est-àdire que vous avez ramassé dans
votre
mémoire toutes les sentiments tous les
souvenirs tout le bien tout ce qui pèse
finalement dans la vie le reste
s'effondre tout comme notre corps il ne
reste que le bien réalisé et c'est ce
que nous présentons aujourd'hui c'est ça
le terrible jugement de Dieu il nous
reprend c'est lui qui veut de nous vous
avez dit
d'elle vous avez dit qu'elle disait si
quelqu'un veut de nous monsieur gluxman
dit
allons-y et bien c'est le bon Dieu
aujourd'hui qui veut d'elle ce n'est
peut-être pas le spectacle que vous
auriez aimé accompagner jusqu'au bout ce
n'est
jamais le geste que nous désirons
intérieurement c'est pourtant celui que
nous posons allons-y jusqu'au bout ce
bien réalisé c'est Dieu lui-même cette
bonté dont les saaueries avez-vous dit
plus que les sauts les insensés ceux qui
ne savent pas qu'ils sont appelés à
vivre éternellement de ce bien
constitué dernier clin d'œil peut-être
l'Église catholique fête le 16 juillet
notre- Dame du Mont Carnel
elle est morte ce
jour-là Notre-Dame du Mont Carmel
revêtue d'une bure brune celle de
l'humilité
je ne reviendrai pas ça peut paraître
paradoxal pour une star peut-être que
c'est une vertu encore plus nécessaire
pour quelqu'un de connu que pour
d'autres je crois que ça peut lui aller
assez
bien et la gloire du Carmel c'est d'être
élevé au
montsillon à côté de la gloire de Dieu
c'est ça notre espérance et c'est ça que
nous voulons pour elle vous pouvez
encore faire quelque chose dans votre
prière vous offrir vous-même à ce désir
profond de faire du bien même à ceux qui
ne sont plus parmi
nous je laisse le dernier mot avant le
mot du bon Dieu pour la prière à
Gabriel comme l'a voulu Jane je vous
invite à me
rejoindre après votre mot madame qui est
le dernier comme elle l'a voulu vous son
intime les pasteurs ici présents et
moi-même poserons les trois derniers
gestes prière bénédiction encensement
pour remettre à Dieu ce qui lui
appartient notre âme et même notre corps
ensuite la famille suivra le corps
jusque à la
à l'extérieur de l'église où nous
l'accompagnerons vous l'accompagnerez
vous par vos applaudissement vous le
savez geste incongru dans une église
s'il en est mais justement geste au
combien liturgique je pèse mes mots pour
une artiste qui ne peut savoir que comme
ça que l'on va rester fidèle
encore
je m'a demandé tu vla
po
is yours and yours and
yours a sleep I shall
have rest i shall have yet death shall
be butter
pause for the peace of my years in the
long green gross will be yours and yours
and
yours
la prière de
remise à
Dieu asking God
Dieu notre Créateur et
Rédempteur par ta puissance le Christ a
vaincu la
mort et est entré dans la
gloire sû de sa victoire et nous
appuyons sur ses promesses
nous confions Jane à ta
miséricorde au nom de Jésus notre
Seigneur qui est mort et qui maintenant
vit et règne avec toi et le
Saint-Esprit pour les siècles et des
siècles amen
amen
trou dans
TER
votre corps connaî aujourd'hui la
corruption et la mort que c'est en son
qui monte comme notre prière élève votre
âme jusqu'à lui pour la faire vivre en
lui
éternel
le Seigneur soit avec
vous avec votre
esprit que par la miséricorde de Dieu
les âmes des fidèles trèspassé repose en
paix et que Dieu tout-puissant vous
bénisse le Père le Fils et le
Saint-Esprit
AMEN
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
S
[Applaudissements]
ça
va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
t'attends
que je
demand
[Musique]
là il
ay
[Musique]
merci
là
[Musique]
J
les
[Musique]
je pense
là-bas
par
ici
déchar
ok ok
c'est
moi
et
voilà
voilà enc
une
alors
[Musique]
là